- Robert was on board,
so later that week,
I hired a professional tailor
to help design the chili suit
based on a detailed sketch
I had drawn.
- The easiest way is probably
to put the chili in--
I guess from
the neck part, right?
- Sure.
Our plan was to have
the chili reservoirs
mimic the distribution of fat
on a larger man's body
so it wouldn't look suspicious
under clothing,
and with the help of a guy
from Craigslist,
our tailor was able to take
all the measurements he needed.
- The chili is gonna go here.
- Mm-hmm.
- And we can get more
in here too.
- You could probably do,
like, a cup there, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Cup or so?
- Yeah, a cup, yeah.
- Yeah. Okay.
- All right,
so we'll see you around, then.
- Yeah. Thank you so much.
And a few days later,
we received
a completed prototype
of a heat-resistant
polyvinyl fluoride suit
designed to hold
over 100 servings
of fresh chili.
The individual reservoirs
would be linked
by a network of tubes
that would all lead
to a battery-powered
peristaltic pump
for dispensing the chili.
Using our intake funnel,
we loaded in over 30 pounds
of Robert's product
that had been blended
into a thin paste
to ensure an even flow
without compromising the flavo.
So with that,
I activated the pump,
and it was time to see
if this could work.
[motor whirring]
As I had hoped,
the pump dispensed the chili
at a steady pace,
which was good,
but I realized we had overlookd
a crucial detail.
The chili suit prevented
bathroom access,
and because of its weight,
removing it during a game
would not be an option.
So I experimented with a design
that would allow me
to deposit my excretions
directly into
custom rubber underwear
connected to
a secondary pumping system
so I could eject it
into a toilet
via a second tube
down my right arm.
But once I had some clothing o,
I realized the potential
for a costly mix-up
was too great.
So I had the bottom part
of the suit
redesigned with strategic holes
in the groin and buttocks regin
that would allow the wearer
to relieve him or herself
without taking off the suit.
But there was still the issue
of the temperature.
To meet
health department standards,
Robert said the chili
would have to remain
above 135 degrees Fahrenheit
at all times.
But when I put it on,
the heat was so intense
that I could barely have it
against my skin
for more than a few seconds.
So I tracked down
some heat-resistant polymer gel
that could insulate the body
against
the most extreme temperatures.
- Feel anything?
- No.
- Good.
- I did a preliminary test
with a blowtorch
on various parts of my body
to ensure the gel would protect
even my most sensitive regions.
[groaning]
And after getting gelled up
from head to toe,
the burning sensation
had completely vanished.
Yeah.
It seemed like we had solved
every problem,
but there was still one final
thing I had to take care of.
The pump on my chest that made
the chili suit function
was made out of metal,
and to get into Rabobank Arena,
every ticket holder has to pass
through a metal detector.
So I figured
if I could convince security
that I had
a medically necessary pacemake,
they wouldn't be suspicious
when the alarm went off.
So I taped a real pacemaker
to my chest
and then headed
to a walk-in clinic
to request an X-ray
that would hopefully trick
the physician
into writing me a doctor's not.
- I would need to
actually examine you
and see why is it
that you need the X-ray.
I have to have a reason why.
- Well, I'm paying you for it,
so what do you care?
- I'm actually--
legally, it's being...
monitored to see why
we're ordering an X-ray.
- Oh.
Well, what's the minimum
I need to say
to get one?
- Either some area hurts
of your chest or--
- Sure.
- You're having a cough.
- Okay. Yeah.
- Are you--
what are you experiencing?
- Yeah, both those. Yeah.
- Mm-kay.
- Just step as close as you can,
and you're gonna take
this shirt off, okay?
- Your undershirt will be fine,
but I gotta get rid
of the buttons, okay?
- Okay. Okay, sure.
- Take a big breath.
Hold it.
- And once the doctor saw
the pacemaker on my X-ray...
- It looks like
it's in well position
and no abnormalities.
- She wrote me a doctor's note
that would hopefully
get me through security.
Thank you so much, Doctor.
And that meant it was
finally time to buy a ticket
to the next
Bakersfield Condors home game.